you know I would tell you that Beth is
an amazing Gift Giver
like she researches gifts
she's one of those people that'll
research a gift for like 60 days when
you open it you're like did you talk to
my third grade teacher like what the
[__]
but the gifts are amazing and I always
tell her man you it took you 60 days you
wasted 59 days
gifts for guys are easy so this is a
song for anybody looking to get a gift
for that special man in their life
I hope this helps
a couple people catching on to the joke
already all right
that's all right everybody look if
you're at my show and you're looking for
my jokes they're right [__] here
they're not oh if you're looking around
for them you're gonna miss them they're
coming right the [__] out your face
[Music]
look for anybody and then
not tonight
[Applause]
you're always so thoughtful
gifts on my special day
asking friends and family about things
that make me feel great
let me try to help you
Let Me ease your mind
because it's pretty easy
you just have to ask us
we'll [__] tell you
I just want a [__] and a sandwich
let me save you some time I'd like a
[__] and a sandwich I don't need
another [__] time and I have my work
alone since the eighth grade you and
your sister use the couple's massage I'm
like a [__] and a sandwich
at the same time
time
[Music]
[Applause]
I like turkey on wheat
I like ham on rice
to make this stay complete well there's
one more thing that I'd like to try
I know when guys say try women always
think that we're talking about anal
because that's true
just not this time
I just like a [__] I ate a sandwich
while I'm watching TV turn on ESPN
little Predators highlights
watching grown and skate around in tight
pants
[Music]
all right
now I know on your special day I'd give
you anything that you need
trips jewelry or your clothing I bring
the moon down to its knees
she doesn't have to tell me
cause I know what she really wants
because she's told me before
[Music]
I've still never done it
haha you'll see why
she says she wants me naked we're
washing dishes
[Applause]
sling masks
quotes from The Notebook over again
I wrote her every single day
[Music]
what Guns N Roses song is like this
patience all right let me see if I can
do this dude's voice at the end of the
show but we'll try we're going to end it
with patience and we're going to get
everybody out of here
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
but I watch TV in bed I promise not to
get any crumbs on your head I just wanna
blow job while I watch some TV
that'll feel so fine to me in a [__]
yay in a sandwich
good job
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you all so much for coming out
here tonight I had a great time
[Applause]